When it comes to good movies, there's a lot
that rides on the actors' performances.
Some roles can't be played without a great
actor at the wheel, and when an actor is at
the height of his or her game, one unforgettable
performance might be enough to nudge an okay
movie up into an award-winning film.
In the case of these films, these actors performances'
were so strong that they're practically perfect.
Bringing the fury
She may not be the title character, but make
no mistake: the star of Mad Max: Fury Road
is definitely Charlize Theron's Imperator
Furiosa.
She's the heart and soul of George Miller's
gorgeous post-apocalyptic road war movie.
Of course, it was Miller who gave Theron such
stellar material to work with, but it's not
hard to imagine the character falling flat
in the hands of a less capable actress.
With Theron behind the wheel, Furiosa is every
bit her name -- a woman of determined fury
hellbent on freeing Immortan Joe's brides
from lives of torment.
Theron creates a true modern icon, embellishing
her determination with a quiet empathy that
shines through in some of the film's calmer
moments.
As Furiosa finally achieves her ends and takes
on the big bad, she grunts what's come to
be the defining line of the film:
"Remember me?"
We sure do, and will continue to do so for
years to come.
Making depression hilarious
Ryan Gosling seems to have dedicated much
of his career onscreen to defying expectations.
After blowing up thanks to a turn in one of
the most beloved romance films of all time,
Gosling took on a litany of strange, uncomfortable
roles in order to distance himself from the
traditional career of a leading man in Hollywood.
This has given us films like The Nice Guys,
which may well mark Gosling's finest hour
as an actor.
Gosling takes on the role of Holland March,
a depressed alcoholic private investigator
in Los Angeles circa 1977.
March is vulnerable, cowardly, and apt to
self-harm.
There's a shocking degree of drama sprinkled
throughout the performance, considering the
film is an action comedy, and Gosling sells
March's darkest moments just as expertly as
his funnier ones.
At the same time, he's also hysterical in
the movie.
His may just be one of the great comedic performances
of the decade, with the kind of timing to
perfectly foil Russell Crowe's straight-man
routine.
"Munich."
"What?"
"A guy without his balls … Munich."
It's a difficult contrast to balance, playing
a life-hating alcoholic who's funny without
compromising his character's identifiability.
It takes an actor as talented as Gosling is
to pull it off.
Burning it down
Even the best films in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are often marred by bland, unmemorable
villains with vaguely-defined goals and personalities.
There are occasional exceptions like Loki...
"Surprise."
...but for the most part, Marvel villains
are uninteresting.
That changed, though, when Michael B. Jordan
hit screens as Erik "Killmonger" Stevens,
the antagonist of Black Panther.
Jordan melds swagger with terror, painting
Killmonger as a sympathetic character who's
just a few adjustments away from being the
film's protagonist.
His background as a poor kid in Oakland, California
feels all too familiar, so much so that the
audience is more likely to relate to him than
to T'Challa''s royal upbringing.
His ultimate inability to distinguish justice
from aimless violence is all the more heartbreaking
because of how close he is to being someone
we love.
Jordan's charming recklessness and seething
hatred make for a character who feels doomed
from the moment we meet him, yet seeing him
finally meet his tragic end still hurts.
Jordan's had some sizable performances before,
of course, but this one is absolutely unforgettable.
Besting the braggadocio
It's always incredible when a young actor
manages to not only hold their own in a film
featuring a slew of major movie stars, but
manages to come out as the standout performer
in the film.
There are few better examples of this than
Hailee Steinfeld's turn in the Coen Brothers'
remake of True Grit.
Steinfeld scored the role of Mattie Ross from
a pool of 15,000 actresses, and she was just
13 when she began filming on what was her
first major movie role.
True Grit tells the story of a young girl
who hires a drunk US Marshal named Rooster
Cogburn to help her track down the man who
killed her father.
And while Steinfeld acts alongside heavy-hitters
like Jeff Bridges, Josh Brolin, and Matt Damon
in the movie, she steals every scene she's
in.
Her take on Ross is snappy, angry, and fierce,
with Steinfeld channeling the character's
laser-like focus on vengeance with the kind
of poise most actors four times her age aren't
capable of portraying.
Some stars go their entire lives without turning
in a performance as authentic as the one Steinfeld
crafted, and she did it on her feature film
debut.
It doesn't get much more impressive than that.
Humanizing the ape
Motion capture performances are becoming just
as impressive and important as live-action
ones, and there's no one better at putting
on a high-tech computer suit than Andy Serkis.
The actor has portrayed quite a few CGI-enhanced
characters of note, including Gollum from
The Lord of the Rings trilogy, Supreme Leader
Snoke from the new Star Wars trilogy, and
Caesar from the Planet of the Apes trilogy.
And he really shines in that last role as
the simian soldier.
Not only is his performance in the role among
the best of his career, but it may just be
the most important motion capture acting of
all time.
Throughout the films, we see Caesar evolve
over the course of several years.
In the beginning, he's a sweet, loving primate
whose intelligence is obvious but who's otherwise
pretty innocent.
By the time we get to the last film, however,
he's soulful, resonant, and all-too-human.
"I came for you..."
Serkis takes the character on a journey from
a young ape confused by his place in the world
to a grizzled, unbreakable leader of a new
nation, and his performance never once falters
along the way.
Yes, the special effects crew does a stellar
job in transferring that performance to animation,
but at its core Serkis' tremendous work proves
that he's a true pioneer in motion capture
acting.
Matching the tempo
J.K. Simmons has pretty much always been impressive.
From his gritty work on the small screen to
his memorable foray into the superhero realm
to his versatile film appearances, he doesn't
seem to miss.
Even his insurance company commercials are
worth watching.
But Simmons' magnum opus is his role as Terence
Fletcher in Whiplash.
In the film, he portrays the jazz professor
from hell -- a maniacally focused and demanding
conductor who berates and abuses his students
until they either achieve brilliance or go
insane.
His simultaneous mentorship and relentless
antagonism of Miles Teller's Andrew is both
engrossing and repulsive.
Simmons strikes the perfect balance of mania,
never going so over the top as to ruin the
audience's suspension of disbelief.
And yet there's a humanity Simmons gives to
Fletcher when he easily could have been a
cartoonish monster.
There are plenty of great iconic movie antagonists,
but Fletcher's realism makes for one that
will haunt any young artist's deepest insecurities.
Elevating the material
It goes without saying, but Meryl Streep is
one of the greatest actors of all time.
Her filmography contains a multitude of flawless
performances, which makes picking just one
sublime showcase next to impossible.
That said, there is one character that simply
would not have worked without her, and that's
Miranda Priestly in The Devil Wears Prada.
The film is based on the novel of the same
name, which tells the story of a college graduate
working as the personal assistant to a tyrannical
editor-in-chief of a fashion magazine.
The film, and her role as Miranda Priestly,
should have been a relatively forgettable
one, but with Streep coming in and bringing
her A-game to the picture, the whole movie
is lifted from simple dramedy status to an
absolute must-see that'll stand the test of
time.
Streep's infinitely quotable ice queen bears
an unwavering facade of steely perfection.
Yet she lets that mask slip just long enough
to allow our young heroine, and the audience
by extension, see the humanity that lies beneath
all that brass.
It's one thing to act well in an already well-crafted
film but it takes a truly magnificent performer
to turn a role like Priestly into an Oscar-nominated
performance.
If Streep's screen talents weren't already
documented enough, her work in The Devil Wears
Prada proves that there's simply no one as
good or as effective as her.
Being a BAMF
There's very little to say about Pulp Fiction
that hasn't already been said.
Quentin Tarantino's masterclass in filmmaking
is arguably the most quotable movie of a generation,
and most of the best lines came from Samuel
L. Jackson's Jules, a righteous hitman who
finds himself in the midst of an existential
crisis over the course of the film.
Jackson is extremely prolific as an actor
and has appeared in a number of Tarantino
films, but it's his turn here that stands
out as one of his finest hours as an actor.
There's a calm, controlled intensity to Jules
that lingers throughout Jackson's performance.
He calculates everything and almost always
has the upper hand, which is why his near-death
experience in the film shakes him to his core.
Jackson makes this experience less an unraveling
and more a crossroads for the character.
It makes his encounter with petty criminals
Ringo and Yolanda all the more riveting and
pivotal.
Consider the controlled rage and desperation
that goes into every line:
"And what's Fonzie like?
Come on Yolanda what's Fonzie like?"
"He's cool."
"What?!"
"Cool."
"Correctamundo."
In a film filled with memorable characters
and performances, Jackson's stands out as
the definitive performance in one of the great
modern American films.
Channeling the insanity
Films based on Stephen King books provide
countless stellar villains to choose from,
from Jack Nicholson's Jack Torrance in The
Shining to Pennywise from It.
However, there's one that seems to stand out
from the rest, even all these years later:
Kathy Bates' Oscar-winning turn as Annie Wilkes
Misery.
Wilkes is fan culture gone toxic — well,
more toxic than it already is.
Her attachment to writer Paul Sheldon's novels
is fanatical, leading her to kidnap him after
a car accident.
Oftentimes when a villain is so memorable,
it's because the actor brings a relatability
one wouldn't expect to the role.
But Wilkes is just not that kind of woman.
Her performance is of someone so unhinged
and unpredictable that it frightens you to
your core.
"What do you think I say when I go to the
feed store in town?"
"Oh now, Wally, get me a bag of that effing
pig feet and 10lbs of that beastly cow corn!"
Bates plays Wilkes as a woman who truly believes
her behavior is normal, which makes it all
the more horrifying when she lashes out at
poor Paul Sheldon.
Sure, it's the leg-smashing scene that really
got everyone talking, but it's Bates' full-package
villainy that rattled everyone's nerves for
the long haul.
"Is this what you're looking for?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!